dado que estos procesos químicos pueden
ser de difícil comprensión podría
resumirnos de manera sencilla de que se
trata Este descubrimiento
Sí buenas tardes para todos el
descubrimiento por el cual se otorga el
premio Nobel consiste en primer lugar
por un descubrimiento hecho por los
investigadores Charles y meldal quien
descubrieron un grupo de reacciones que
se conocen como reacciones clic estas
reacciones Se caracterizan por ser muy
rápidas tener una eficiencia muy alta y
además de eso no generar sus productos
estas reacciones para entenderlo de un
poco más sencillo permiten unir dos
moléculas pertenecientes a sustancias
que tienen comportamientos diferentes y
propiedades diferentes a través de un
enlace que podríamos suponer que
funciona de una manera muy similar como
funciona el velcro este digamos que ese
descubrimiento de estos dos
investigadores abrió las puertas para
que se pudieran llevar a cabo procesos
en sistemas vivos como los que ha venido
estudiando la profesora bertosi quien ha
empleado reacciones tipo clic para
modificar
modificar polisacáridos en el interior
de las células sin afectar su
comportamiento esto ha permitido que por
ejemplo se logren marcar con colorantes
o con sustancias fluorescentes proteínas
o polisacáridos como los glucanos Y de
esa manera entender mejor Cómo
interactúan las células frente a
diferentes patógenos Como por ejemplo
los virus y también ha servido o ha sido
muy importante para estudiar los
mecanismos a través de los cuales actúan
los fármacos que se usan para
tratamiento del cáncer digamos que los
descubrimientos de ellos no solamente se
limita a digamos al tratamiento de
enfermedades o a la cura del cáncer sino
que se ha convertido en una herramienta
muy importante para el desarrollo de
nuevos materiales para la modificación
de superficies para la obtención de
polímeros por ejemplo antimicrobianos Es
una herramienta que se ha venido
implementando exitosamente en los
laboratorios de química en todo el mundo
y ha permitido que los químicos podamos
y podamos una unir moléculas que tienen
diferentes comportamientos Y de esa
manera obtener materiales con
propiedades que antes eran imaginables
inimaginables la química convencional
digamos no clic
se caracteriza por ser por tener
reacciones que son muy lentas reacciones
de poca eficiencia y reacciones que no
son tan específicas
si esto es descubrimientos que suponen
en el ámbito de la salud en general
concretamente en el de los enfermos de
cáncer puede suponer que se cree nuevos
medicamentos quizás más baratos que los
actuales
Sí yo creo que va a conllevar y está
conllevando porque actualmente hay
muchas investigaciones que se están
llevando a cabo empleando en las
reacciones descubiertas por los
galardonados con el premio Nobel y lo
que va a permitir es que se puedan
obtener fármacos que presenten una mayor
eficiencia que sean menos tóxicos como
los que tenemos actualmente y que sean
más específicos a llegar al sitio de
acción donde donde está localizado El
tumor o las células que específicamente
se quieren atacar y no solamente digamos
que el el los avances que se generan con
con los descubrimientos con los
descubrimientos de estos científicos se
limitan al campo de la salud sino como
le decía anteriormente al desarrollo de
sensores al desarrollo de superficie
inteligentes por ejemplo también se ven
favorecidos con el desarrollo con el
desarrollo planteado por estos
científicos